foreign
[Music]
it's such a pleasure to be back with
film independent this really feels very
homey to me so we does I'm sorry the Q a
like almost 12 years ago we did we did
so for for Tiny Furniture and we look
exactly the same as we did then yeah I
mean hardly anything's happened between
then and now literally nothing
excuse my notes I have a tendency to
forget things in my old age and also I
think because of covid
um welcome to my I don't even have like
any good excuse for why I have a
tendency to forget that my on screen my
onset notes are such a intense deranged
scribble series that no one else and if
I lose them I become uh cataclysmic and
yet I constantly lose them so yeah plot
your notes I take more notes now in this
time in my life than I ever did before
like even when I was in school even when
I was in classes I keep notes of life I
really get my notes app if anybody wants
to talk about their love of notes app
later I'm around
foreign
you can hashtag things now it's great
I didn't know that
to check that out we'll talk
um so
since uh so many film independent
members are aspiring filmmakers which I
love I love to ask the aspiring
filmmaker story so
um do you want to talk about how you
became a filmmaker is that originally
what you set out to do
you know I it's funny I started in a way
so young that now I look back and I
think how could I have set out to do
anything before that I was like
basically fetal but at the time it felt
like a real idea that I suddenly had I
was um I always loved to write and I
always wrote as a kid I was always like
if there was ever you know an irritating
poetry or playwriting elective you could
sign up for or a lit mag you could
submit to or I was incessantly sending
things to like Stone Soup the national
children's literature magazine and
getting polite rejection notes six
months later
um and when I went to college in at
Oberlin in Ohio I studied creative
writing and film studies and I thought
that I wanted to be a playwright and I
was like that is a way that I think I I
thought what so many of us thought which
is like I did I knew I loved movies but
I didn't know who made them or how you
would make them I knew that I was lucky
and that my parents are artists and so I
thought a creative life was a
possibility which I realized now was
such a a very blessed Advantage because
so many people and I'm sure many of you
come from families where the idea of
pursuing something creative is
considered a long shot or something that
would be impractical or there's like the
lack of support for even that and so
um I wanted to be a playwright and I
thought you know I had a whole plan in
my head about you know writing plays and
putting them on in garages and maybe
like teaching English to some teenagers
to some Scrappy teenagers and and then I
uh actually really my life was really
changing because I went into I have told
Andrew budalski
um that he really changed my life
because I went into the local video
store
um that was um in my Tribeca
neighborhood rest in peace and I saw the
movie funny haha on the shelf and I
picked it up I was 20 and I watched it
and I thought this is a person who is
close to my age who clearly has limited
resources who is just setting up the
camera and letting life happen and it
was almost like I think we all have a
moment where it's like
the the barrier to entry that we've had
mentally for whatever we're pursuing
Falls away just a little bit and for me
it was seeing that movie
um and from there I started to really
try to understand not how I could be a
filmmaker in this sense but how I could
be a filmmaker in the sense of you know
what is that it was just when the pd-170
camera was coming out and everyone's
talking about how David Lynch had shot
Inland Empire on this camera and so I
took all my babysitting money and
um like literally that I had been like
keeping basically in a piggy bank since
high school and went and bought this
prosumer camera and started making short
films in college which led to making a
sort of baby feature called creative
nonfiction and um through my
um incessant uh email harassment of
various Mumble core filmmakers I was
able to learn more and more about what
they were doing and figure out that
South by Southwest was a place that
where Janet Pearson who was new who's an
amazing woman who was near newly running
the the festival then would be open to
showing something
graduated moved back to New York had a
variety of jobs I worked as a restaurant
hostess I worked as a babysitter I
worked in a baby's clothing store
literally like a store that sold like
cashmere rompers Ferry very specific
this was pre-recession and I was and my
first film was accepted to South by
Southwest creative nonfiction
um and that's when I sort of thought is
there a slightly more ambitious way to
do this and at the first Festival I had
met a group of young men who had gone to
NYU Jody Lee lights Kyle Martin Sean
Durkin Antonio Campos all of whom were
starting to make movies on a much more
ambitious level than I could conceive of
I look back now and they were still you
know tiny bit to me a film crew of six
was like impossible to conceive of and I
started collaborating with Jody that led
to creative non-fiction that led to Tiny
Furniture and my my life was really
blasted open by by that and um and so I
feel a little bit because I didn't have
like a sort of picture of what my career
was going to look like it was just this
really desperate desire to tell stories
and to figure out the kind of next best
way to make things that I've been doing
that ever since I probably could have
Stu I probably could still stand to have
like a slightly clearer picture about
how it all fits together but it's like
the moment I finished something I just
become so obsessed with what the next
thing is going to look like what kind of
challenge it's going to be and and I
feel like that's led me here today I
mean I know you're beyond garage theater
but I still want to see that I still
want to see Elena Dunham presents garage
theater well maybe I'm gonna have the
chance I mean I will say that like
anytime I do something that is it's such
a joy always to work with a big film
crew but anytime I get to do something
that is stripped down and small and
Scrappy like I made a film last year
called sharp stick that we shot at the
end of 2020
um really in the coveted bubble
pre-vaccine very small crew 14-day shoot
and just being back in that space that's
sort of where kids putting on a play
Space
um I just I always will be attracted to
the kind of community and Ingenuity that
comes from limited resources which is
something I always say when I meet young
or aspiring filmmakers who are
frustrated by the scale on which they're
able to do things is that I feel like
some of them like I'm not trying to
bemoan the amazing chance to make other
things but I feel like
um it's a reminder to me to always
appreciate the resources I have when I
have them because of the of what it does
what does come out of being forced to
kind of strip down and strip back and
tell stories in that way so maybe the
garage theater will happen that's I mean
I really hope so and that's an amazing
story I didn't realize you'd been
inspired by Mumble core filmmakers like
that's
awesome I didn't even know what Mumble
core was until I started working at film
independent in 2007 2008. I just
remember thinking like I saw Andrew
budrellski's movie which led me to
seeing Joe Swanberg which led me to
um seeing I had actually gone to high
school with rybrew so young who was also
working with those people and I started
to work with her we wrote a screenplay
together
um and just you know Greta Gerwig you
know it was really interesting that was
when Barry Jenkins was just putting out
medicine for melancholy it was a really
I literally you know saw his first
shorts on MySpace and it was a really
amazing moment because
you know it's like the only analogy I
could say is like film for a second
almost felt like indie rock or like
garage Rock not that I didn't know what
that is I'm a complete and total nerd
but but that being said like I think
that it felt really alive and really
specific and you never know when you're
living through a really kind of cool
cultural moment that it was that but I
look back and
um I ran into somebody who I knew from
that kind of South by Southwest period
last night and I just thought like
what a amazing moment that we lived
through of getting to make movies I
remember seeing the duplos brothers
first movie that they did on an iPhone
that was about an answering machine like
a botched answering machine recording
and just being but I also was also very
conscious of the fact that most of these
filmmakers were men and most of these
was that before puffy chair or after
that was before puffy wow it was a
pre-puffy chair duplex Brothers adapter
and and all those filmmakers are
incredible but I was like Ryan I would
often talk about the fact that we were
dealing in a complete boys club we
didn't know any women who worked on
cruise we didn't know any it was a very
CIS white male
environment and so trying to figure out
how to sort of understand those
resources and then use them to tell the
kinds of stories that interested us was
something we were always talking about
yeah uh yeah I think it's amazing I mean
you mentioned uh you know the funny
thing about it is so many people made
fun in Mumble core and but I really do
think when you look back now like so
many of the filmmakers Now sort of stood
on their are standing on their shoulders
and you mentioned Antonio Campos like he
just did the staircase on HBO yeah no
and Sean Durkin has a show coming out
and I mean these it's funny because it
was a moment where it was easy to make
fun of the idea of like these kind of
hipsters improvising in their garages
but it did have a kind of Ingenuity to
it I think that hadn't come around in a
while and like all movements every film
doesn't age perfectly I wouldn't say
that my work from that time ages
perfectly and but I think that they're
and also was easy for people to say it
was craftless but I think there was a
craft to it and there was a style to it
and there's so many there was just so
many smart
um and really like really Innovative
people who were around in that moment
but yes the Mumble core jokes come
strong and steady I think it probably
could have stood to have a better name
yeah
yeah I don't know exactly where that
came from we could have called it like
like
um like uh early Arts naturalism or
something I mean if it feels like all
the core words came after Mumble Court
too like Cottage core like that totally
became like a cut there's a lot of
there's a lot of core happening yeah and
so let's talk about Catherine colberti
this sounds phenomenal I love it so much
I've been recommending it to all my
friends for a whole month and so much
uh this is adapted from a y a novel
young adult novel from 1994. how so how
did you come in contact with the novel
and then want to adapt it into a film I
came into contact with it on the new
releases soft cover children Shelf at
the Barnes and Noble in Union Square
um where my dad would take me every
Saturday
and it was one of those books that you
pick up and you realize by the time
you've left oh so you've known this from
way back you were like an OG lover of
this book for the first time when I was
10 and then it became like you know we
all have that sort of book that's like a
safety book and it became that for me I
realized like I would probably reread it
once twice a year it just was I think
there were so many books where I had
admired the heroines but there were very
few where I had identified with them and
I also loved historical fiction the way
like some kid like this was my Harry
Potter
it was like I the way that some kids
become obsessed and kind of like
disappear into the cavern of their
imagination like this was that for me
and she's written a Karen Cushman the
author has written a series of
incredible books for young readers as
she would call them
um and about
um kind of children living through
complex historic periods I could just
picture you at 10 saying to your friends
something like oh my God you guys the
1200s were so cool you have to read this
book if I'd had any friends I would have
said that to them
so um
so did you read quite a bit of why a and
do you have what's your relationship
with Y A because I think I feel like
sometimes people make fun of Y A like
we're talking people make making fun of
Mumble core or they kind of
downplay the importance of why I'm
wondering what your opinion of why I
really am pretty I really love
children's literature like that sort of
my if I want like I love there's some y
books I absolutely adore too and I think
why isn't important genre and I think
people make fun of why the same way that
people make fun of young people in any
genre that is specifically designated
for teenage girls or young queer people
is always made fun of whether it's like
you know like comic books or boy bands
or like there's a way that that
vocations that are given to people young
people it's like people don't make fun
of high school sports these are things
that are so important to the emotional
and intellectual development of young
people I love children's literature just
because I think there's something about
just reverting to that child mind space
that's absolutely unbelievable and so I
was always really obsessed with things
like you know Eloise and um and I loved
I loved um all of the uh Marie Sendak
books and like animated playful
um and this book kind of felt like it
was the like just the continuation of
that and it's funny because as a kid I
read a lot of books for adults like I
was the kid who like stole Lolita off my
parents shelf because I heard it had sex
scenes and read it and was like I
couldn't find a single one because I
didn't understand anything I was reading
yeah I read the I read my mom's copy of
uh Color Purple at like 11. somebody
asked me what I thought about the
lesbian content in it and I was like
what yeah you totally lesbian
but but um I really got excited about
the idea I mean I've been trying to make
this movie for 10 years but when I I
loved the idea of making something
speaking of why a you know film for me
as a as a young teenager was so
important especially being someone who
felt a little bit socially isolated so
whether it was you know clueless or A
League of Their Own or slums of Beverly
Hills like these were these movies that
just totally formed my identity and I
was really excited about trying to make
a film that could be sort of appropriate
for
um younger viewers but also kind of just
honored their intelligence and like the
how much they do know and wasn't
pandering and didn't assume that their
primary interests were romance or you
know popularity or and so I felt like in
so far as I know what a good role model
is that this character is a really great
role model and I was excited by the idea
that there could be a movie that the way
that you know my father I just
remembered that my last night that my
dad and I when I was 11 got there was a
sold out show so we went to go see
original sin together and like I had a
panic attack like my dad was just like I
don't know what to do I've made a huge
mistake but that's like a really that's
a really gnarly sex scene and like that
was like famed at the time Angelina
Jolie Antonio Banderas but most of the
time we went to see appropriate movies
together and the way that that intergen
the way that we could talk about so many
hard topics that were hard to Broach you
know I found that often the only way
that I could talk to my parents even
though they were very open about things
like feeling socially isolated or
confused about you know certain ideas or
yearnings was when there was like a
piece of art that reflected those
feelings that we could then just
together and so I loved the idea of
trying to make a movie that was that
kind of touch point for young people and
their families hopefully that was the
dream
so in terms of writing is this your
first project that was an adaptation and
not
um all the all the ideas coming from you
when um I co-created camping which any
Conor that was adapted from a UK format
which is sort of a different thing but
but has similar similar aspects but this
was and I had adapted novels
unsuccessfully not to not made taking
them to screen before but I felt like
this was the first successful adaptation
I did insofar as a it got made but B it
um it felt like it was the first time
I'd really been able to capture the
spirit of the thing that I loved in the
thing that I was writing and the
interesting thing about adapting is that
it's not necessarily about taking the
plot verbatim but it's about like
keeping the kernel of the thing that
made you love the original so much and
making sure that even if an audience has
no has anyone here read Catherine called
birdie
seeds oh we've got one oh that's so
thrilling
[Music]
um thank you it must have I must have
felt like a lot of pressure because I've
heard this book was very well loved by
you and many many many other people it
was very simple like a lot it was very
loved by a very specific like I read an
article four years ago in nylon that was
amazing that was somebody talking about
how Catherine called birdie was their
way of figuring out their queerness or
an amazing comic was in the times a few
years ago about someone talking about
how it was her escape from her household
as a kid like it wasn't the most popular
book it didn't sell you know it didn't
sell crazy commercial numbers but the
people who love it really love it and so
it's one of those kind of cult things
must be how my husband feels about
Sandman but um
but uh it's
um because he was really panicked he did
approve of the adaptation but he was
very panicked before we watched
um but I think that it's it was it I
wanted to make sure that I did right by
the author who I love so much Karen who
is 80 and lives on Vashon Island off
Seattle and is a total badass and
buy this book that had meant so much to
me and then as the cast and crew also
started to fall in love with the
characters in the story I felt like okay
we've really gotta try to bring this
home
so you were originally supposed to shoot
this in 2000 right and then got derailed
by the pandemic the pandemic we were
about to shoot we were supposed to shoot
in April 2020 and you can all imagine
what happened
um and you know we got that call and I
thought like okay we'll be down for a
week like I can learn to do yoga and
then
um and then obviously
um it didn't happen and of course there
were many more tragic things than the
film not getting to go but I was at the
time so bereft and disappointed and and
concerned that it wouldn't happen again
um and I'm so grateful because Amazon
took the movie after
um you know it had that experience of
getting on the old Hollywood drop and
um they took it and really guided it
beautifully and the pandemic ended up
being
um that time I'm really grateful for it
because the script actually changed a
lot in that time of me just being like I
had a movie that was totally ready to go
with a basically completely different
third act and and the pandemic allowed
the space to reflect
um more to think about my cast doing
these things to dream and to ultimately
come up with an ending that felt like it
was better suited so you completely
changed the third act yeah in your
downtime in our in the down time I was
like let's make a couple tweaks here and
a couple tweaks turned into wow a
totally the entire sword fight and her
father
um coming to her Aid was is that very
you to rewrite very much
you know I tend to rewrite a lot right
up into the point that we go and then
often
um you know through rehearsal process
will also make changes with the actors
and then on the day once we have a
blocking rehearsal once I start to
understand okay often then I'll even go
you know what I realized half of the
stuff in this scene we actually don't
need and just start xing out lines which
some people love and some people love
less
um but I really I always tend to think
like until you are shooting that there's
always potentially a better version and
then even after you're shooting which is
why editors are so brilliant
so let's talk about Bella Ramsey in your
other cast Bella Ramsay who I don't know
if anybody else did but the minute you
saw her on Game of Thrones was like
I really hope that she's gonna be huge
because she is amazing like who is that
girl yes and I had that experience and
everyone I know had that I mean whenever
I told anyone who I cast and they'd go
who's Bella Ramsay what have they been
in and I would say they were that tiny
little warlord on the last season of
Game of Thrones and they'd be like oh my
fucking god and
she really I mean anytime I post it's
just like 1 000 people writing lady
Marmot in all capital letters which I
love and what's amazing is that was her
first role she was 11. she had barely
been acting she was in a theater troupe
in Leicester where she comes from in
England and Nina Gold or casting
director went looking for people for
this role and found Bella and a few
weeks later she was on set on Game of
Thrones and she is
an incredibly fast learner like a
complete I would say she's a savant
except she's good at so many things
she's she makes music there's a song of
hers in this film that she did with my
husband
um and she she Nina suggests when I sent
the script to Nina Gold she said I think
I know the person for this and she
showed me the picture of Bella and I
recognize I was like oh I ca I was angry
that I didn't think of it myself and I
felt at that moment like there was just
absolutely no one else who could do the
role and that was one of my Terrors
actually during the pandemic was I was
like I don't know if I can make this
movie without Bella and if two years go
by and I see Bella and she has grown
into like a full you know that's always
the thing was she with young people it's
like you don't want to say it but they
do grow and at a certain point no longer
look 14.
um so I felt terrible I'd like be
zooming with her and I'd be like just
let me know if you've grown any inches
in any way
but she is just um she's everything like
she's every she's as as wonderful as I
think she is as an actor how how old was
she when you started shooting when we
started shooting she was 17. 17. she was
17. we cast her when she was 15 should
we started shooting when she was 17 and
she's 19 now and
um as wonderful as she is as an actor
and you guys will see more she's on this
show called The Last of Us that's coming
on HBO
as wonderful as she is an actor she's
more remarkable as a person and you know
it takes a lot to be the number one on a
call sheet it's like a a real
responsibility and and if someone has
negativity or
um even a lot of insecurity it can bring
a really different energy to set and
just people were in awe of Bella every
single day and I mean she's killing it
from the first second and I was just so
delighted but also the whole rest of
your cast is too and all those scenes
that she has with more winner
that like veteran UK actress isn't she
incredible with Leslie sharp I cast
she's been in so many things well I've
been obsessed with her ever since
because I've Mike Lee's naked yes and
she has this incredible role in naked
and I and then she's done so many
interesting films so much it's theater
so much television I mean she just like
she do full monty the movie full monty I
think she did she's been in everything
but I naked was my sort of my foray my
entree into her and
um and she's incredible I mean that she
just came in and was like I think she
might be Scottish I think she might have
walked all the way from the Scottish
Highlands and asked for a job and I was
like great done like who am I to argue
with that logic and the last in the
wedding scene she's holding her real
life dog Mrs miggins she just was like I
think I should hold Mrs Megan's in the
scene again and you're like I think
you're right yeah I think you're a
hundred percent right
so let's talk about Andrew Scott the
Beloved
um I heard that uh Rallo was one of the
characters that's changed quite a bit
from the book
um can you talk about like how he has
changed yeah well so once we cast Bella
I wanted to cast from the from the child
outward and make sure that the parents
felt like they reflected who she was and
then I saw her and I was like well I
feel like that person's father is you
can see it obviously Andrew Scott he
created that child and I really think he
had you never know in films if it feels
like people are a successful family it's
one of the leaps of faith that we have
to take in movies although families look
all different ways and I just think they
they really make a handsome Trio but um
but I I was desperate for him to do the
role and in the book it's a much more
brutish part it's like a belching
raging kind of lecherous man and Andrew
and I had a discussion and he was really
honest he was like I really love the
characters I really love the script I
feel like he is feeling a little bit
like a sort of cartoon of this idea of
like let's call it toxic masculine
entity and I really obviously Andrew's
honesty made me even more it's like
someone being like I'm interested but
I'm not really sure that we would make a
great couple and you're like we would
make a great couple
and so I I started to just to talk to
him about who the character could be and
this idea that maybe he also feels very
trapped by the by the time and by the
expectations of the time and the thing
is is that sort of you know we all
suffer under the gender binary so the
idea that only women are suffering from
our ideas of what femininity needs to
look like leaves out the idea that
there's also an enormous amount of
pressure when men are forced to conform
to ideas of what masculinity needs to
look like and so that was sort of the
jumping off point for us talking about
this character and then we just started
to really make ourselves laugh with like
the idea of like what if he kind of is
like the equivalent of like a dad I kind
of talked about them as the equivalent
of like people on The Real Housewives of
New Jersey who kind of buy a mcmansion
that they can't afford and then like the
power keeps getting shut off and they're
always like you know wearing like
matching Gucci track suits like I was
sort of being like well who is their
modern
equivalent that we can talk about and
it's and what would this be and their
kind of pretensions around class which
is very English but also very everywhere
and so Andrew and I really started I
think how I keep looking up at him like
he's here um Andrew and I started to
he's always with us all but he started
to talk about who he could be and then
we got this kind of pearl necklace
wearing damn dancing Dandy and I just I
he just someone my favorite do any of
you do letterboxed
isn't it such a good app
I'm in no way paid to say that I just
love letterbox it's like the only social
media app like even when people are mean
they're so smart that it's okay
whereas on other apps you're like you
didn't even try to spell that but um
but
um someone was like I love this movie in
which Andrew Scott plays Patsy from
absolutely fabulous and I was like yep
100 percent
I feel like he gets the most difficult
Parts because he has to be the Baddie in
this and yet is still really likable at
times but but also he's the one that has
to force his wife to try to have babies
over and over and again and you're just
like do I like this guy I don't know it
was so cute in fleabag I know he's
confusing me he's confusing me too but
then he really I think kind of like what
we wanted to make sure was that you
understood that even though he did
things that we would consider to be
totally kind of darksided as the kids
say
um
I think that's what the kids say my
brother was like kids don't say that but
um
but I think that he is always like
working from this place of passion and
intensity and love for his family and
lack of love for himself and I feel like
Andrew is such a complicated it takes a
very complicated performer a very smart
performer to be able to do something
that's layered like
you know something I always thought
about on girls was like Adam Driver
played a man who in some scenes seemed
like a romantic hero and in some scenes
really bordered on like near sociopathic
disregard for other people and it takes
a very nuanced complicated performer to
be able to move between those two
polarities and keep you engaged and keep
you rooting for them and he's so good at
doing that and I also love actors
specifically male actors who don't have
a fear of always needing to look like
the good guy or the cool guy and Andrew
really just wants to do the truthful
thing
um and I just I hope I get to work with
him over and over again I admire him
yeah I mean by the time you get to the
end and you get stabbed I'm like no I
know we had a big debate about like how
big should the cut be should we think
he's going to die it can't be so small
that you just think he could put a
Band-Aid on it but um but yeah that was
my that was for sure my first sword
fight I was really nervous that morning
because I was like this is like some
Ridley Scott shit up in here and then I
realized it's like you know eight extras
and two men fencing on a ball
pile of hay but it felt really big to me
um we've talked for a very long time and
I think probably you want to go soon but
I was wondering um I want to say feel
long because I'm with you I'm with you
all that's so sweet Linda
um
uh I wanted to ask I mean it was very
exciting to me to find out that you're
doing movies again is is that the
direction that you're heading again I
wouldn't be upset if you headed back to
TV at all well thank you I still watch
your stuff no matter what but I was
really excited to find you doing
features again so I'm just wondering if
I'm certainly not gonna take another 12
years off of making features like the
bug bit me again and I'm definitely need
to be making movies and I really feel
like I am so grateful for that time
because it took me back
um it took me on a really interesting
path and I feel like I sort of like
acquired the skills necessary to push it
but I still feel like in some ways a
baby feature filmmaker like this is
still really new and thrilling to me I
hope it stays new and thrilling to me so
I am certainly going to keep making
movies and I have a couple of TV things
that I'm hoping to do as well but I
would like my future to really hold the
balance of the two to because I have
been reminded that this was my first
love for a reason and I love making TV
and I love making film and I'm not doing
a sort of uh qualitative analysis but
they are truly different things and I
think there was a moment we sort of
tried to decide they were all the same
thing and for the sake of movie lovers
and for TV lovers we can establish that
like well they share commonalities
they're different yeah storytelling
mediums right
um so this is currently on on Amazon
until the end of time until the end of
time it's always when we are all living
on Mars together
um living out our final days it will
still be on Amazon Prime and uh I'm
gonna say you know what I haven't seen
in 50 years Catherine called birdie yes
let's fire it up let's that's what we're
gonna do
um so you were telling me you also have
a podcast
it's called the c word oh my god oh my
god well this is gonna flip out about
that cheer thank you I need to go tell
her that these this you have some
podcast groupies here and she's gonna be
so happy it's amazing um Alyssa is like
the most invested in heart rate back oh
this is the most invested in everyone
listen to our podcast she answers every
comment she's the queen of keeping tabs
so you guys Alyssa says what up
um but uh turkey podcast is about women
who've been considered the c word crazy
throughout history and kind of looking
at
um what their lives what in what
culturally we project onto them and the
deal with their lives so we're always
taking you just gave me a potential
subject backstage did you do Mary Todd
Lincoln very famous thought to be crazy
person
amazing one that we're constantly
thinking about
and you guys can always nominate also by
writing on Instagram we're very engaged
with our nominations we just did a
two-parter on Lindsay Lohan and if you
look at the Sunset Boulevard uh a big
billboard that's up it says that the
Johanna Sons is upon us so just in time
you anticipated that we felt it because
we feel connected to her so we are
always but it's always the low
Renaissance for us it's a 24 7 thing so
um it's a real pleasure to be here with
you and to be here with all of you and
thank you so much for taking the time
thank you Lena thank you
[Music]